عايزين معكم اذا مشاهدينا في متابعه هذه
الصور من قصص جمهوري في السودان حيث توقيع
على اطراف السودانيه اتفاقا الايطاليه
ليؤسس سلطه
لسلطه المدنيه في البلاد نشاهد في الصور
الان رئيس مجلس السياده الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان وكذلك نائب رئيس مجلس السياده
محمد حمدان نقله والذين وقع عليه على
الاتفاق الاطاري الان الذي يتوقع ان يؤسس
لسلطه مدنيه في البلاد وانهاء الازمه
الراهنه في البلاد ايضا همم ابرز القوه
المواقع ايضا على هذا الاعلان السياسي في
قوه الحريه والتغيير المجلس المركزي
والجبهه الثوريه السودانيه والحزب الاتحاد
الافريقي الاصل
مشاهدينا هذه الفرح داخل هذه القاعه بعد
توقيع كبار المسؤولين وكبار قاده الكيانات
السياسيه والكتل السياسيه الكبيره في
البلاد على هذا الاتفاق الايطالي السياسي
في السودان